good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how to beat your
depression so some people might fear
girls not liking them back some people
might fear sharks some people might fear
death but for me for a large part of my
life
I feared myself I feared my truth I
feared my honesty I feared my
vulnerability and that fear and me feel
like I was forced into a corner I was
forced into a corner and there was only
one way out and so I thought about that
way every single day I thought about it
every single day and if I'm being
totally honest standing here I've
thought about it again cents because
that's the sickness that's the struggle
that's depression and depression isn't
chicken pox you don't beat it once and
it's gone forever it's something you
live with it's something you live in
it's the roommate you can't kick out
it's the voice you can't ignore it's the
feelings you can't seem to escape and
the scariest part is the scariest part
is is that after a while you become numb
to it
it becomes normal for you and what you
really fear the most
isn't the suffering inside of you it's
the stigma inside of others it's the the
shame it's the embarrassment it's the
disapproving look on a friend's face
it's the so whispers in the hallway that
you're a week it's the comments that
you're crazy that's what that's what
keeps you from getting help that's what
makes you hold it in and hide it it's
the stigma so you hold it in and you
hide it and you hold it in and you hide
it and even though it's keeping you in
bed every day and it's making your life
feel empty no matter how much you try
and fill it you hide it because the
stigma in our society around depression
is very real it's very real and if you
think that it isn't ask yourself this
would you rather make your next facebook
status say you're having a tough time
getting out of bed because you hurt your
back we're having a tough time getting
out of bed every morning because you're
depressed that's the stigma because
unfortunately we live in a world where
if you break your arm everyone runs over
to sign your cast but if you tell people
you're depressed everyone runs the other
way
that's the stigma we are so so so
accepting of any body part breaking down
other than our brains and that's
ignorant
that's pure ignorance that ignorance has
created a world that doesn't understand
depression that doesn't understand
mental health and that's ironic to me
because depression is one of the best
documented problems we have in the world
yet was one of the least discussed we
just push it aside and put it in a
corner and pretend it's not there and
hope it'll fix itself well it won't it
hasn't and it's not going to because
that's wishful thinking and wishful
thinking isn't a game plan is
procrastination we can't procrastinate
on something this important the first
step in solving any problem is
recognizing there is one well we haven't
done that so we can't really expect to
find an answer when we're still afraid
of the question and I I don't know what
the solution is I wish I did but I don't
but I think I think it has to start here
it has to start with me it has to start
with you it has to start with the people
who are suffering the ones who are
hidden in the shadows we need to speak
up and shatter the silence we need to be
the ones who are brave for what we
believe in because if there's one thing
that I've come to realize if there's one
thing that I see is the biggest problem
it's not in building a world where we
eliminate the ignorance of others it's
in building a world where we teach the
acceptance of ourselves we're okay with
who we are because when we get honest we
see that we all struggle and we all
suffer whether it's with this whether
it's with something else we all know
what it is to hurt we all know what it
is to have pain in our heart we all know
how important it is to heal but right
now depression is society's deep cut
that we're content to put a band-aid
over and pretend it's not there well it
is there it is there and you know what
it's okay depression is okay if you're
going through and know that you're okay
I know that you're sick you're not weak
and it's an issue not an identity
because when you get past the fear and
the ridicule and the judgment and the
stigma of others you can see depression
for what it really is
and that's just a part of life just a
part of life and as much as I hate as
much as I hate some of the places some
of the parts of my life depression has
dragged me down to in a lot of ways I'm
grateful for it because yeah it's put me
in the valleys but only to show me
there's Peaks and yeah it's dragged me
through the dark but only to remind me
there is light my pain more than
anything in nineteen years on this
planet has given me perspective of my
hurt my hurts forced me to have hope
have hope and to have faith faith in
myself faith in others faith that they
can get better that we can change this
that we can speak up and speak out and
fight back against ignorance fight back
against intolerance more than anything
learn to love ourselves learn to accept
ourselves for who we are the people we
are not the people the world wants us to
be because the world I believe in is one
we're embracing your light doesn't mean
ignoring your dark the world I believe
in is one we're measured by our ability
to overcome adversities not avoid them
the world I believe in is one where I
can look someone in the eye and say I'm
going through hell and they can look
back at me and go me too and that's okay
and it's okay because depression is okay
we're people we're people and we
struggle and we suffer and we bleed and
we cry and if you think that true
strength means never showing any
weakness then I'm here to tell you
you're wrong you're wrong because it's
the opposite we're people and we have
problems we're not perfect and that's
okay so we need to stop the ignorance
stop the intolerance stop the stigma and
stop the silence and we need to take
away the taboos take a look at the truth
and start talking because the only way
we're gonna beat a problem
that people are battling alone is by
standing strong together
by standing strong together and I
believe that we can
let's go back to the press now because
it's so much more fun notice she knows
exactly where to go
does she know what to do to get
depressed yes or no she would have you
believe that happens to her when all I
did was tell her you guys okay I know
exactly - go ahead get depressed get
back to 9 level of depression again
don't go to 10 you nod your head when
you're back to 9 focus on what you focus
on
is this a Freudian thing what's that
is this a Freudian thing I don't know
you tell me all I know is you keep
twisting that thing real tight you're
rubbing it off now so what you doing
here
you get back to that depression thing
come on get back to that depression
thing level 8 nod when you're there okay
tell me what you're focusing on right
now to be depressed at level 8
what are you picturing what do you what
are you focusing on what are you
remembering specifically to be depressed
at level 8 or 9 pardon me I don't know
you're not there what do you focused on
the men that you can't trust from your
past now by the way keep stay in that
state how many noticed the pattern
that's different with her head when
she's hopeful than when she's depressed
a very simple pattern ready and if
you've seen it what does she do their
head continuously when she's depressed
and frustrated when she's hopeful what
was she doing with her head how many saw
that pattern that's Universal by the way
what do you say to yourself to be
depressed like this just say out loud
what you're saying in your head when
you're really depressed I'm so pathetic
I'm so pathetic
santé tone of voice you say it when you
stay depressed though there's some
sympathetic your so what else do you say
besides your sympathetic to really be
depressed what do you got to say to
yourself really depressed nine say it
the tone of voice you say it when you're
that depressed I want to live my life
this way what else do you say so
pathetic I don't want to live my life
this way is there a tone of voice here
ladies and gentlemen yes or no loud or
quiet up tone or down crying the voice
or not what else do you say to stay
depressed at level nine you ever get
depressed at ten like we want to kill
yourself now I thought we had a good
suicide we could deal with you
sorry to disappoint you doing smiling in
what you feeling right now
notice how fast we take her from
depression how fast we take her out
impression how fast two seconds if you
with her depression she's pissed off at
you I'm sitting here being depressed you
take me out of it I'll take you out I'll
come out of my depression when I'm ready
everybody Pete up to me hmm something to
think about so we now know what she does
when she's pissed and we know what she
doesn't need to depressed and she seems
to snap back let's go back to hopeful
for a second you you're good you're good
okay the big bucks that's right honey
vamonos how many how many recognize the
physiology of hopeful when she went
there raising have you recognized what
did she do she started doing what nine
her head shoulders came back hand came
up what else did she do start a smile so
can she go from depressed the hopeful
instead of depressed the pissed if you
chose to okay let's get that these are
wimpy states have you ever had a state
of pure ecstasy or is that what you're
pissed about problem that's not a
problem
look at this big smile that's not a
problem good what are you feeling now no
don't change what you feeling when
you're found like that there you go what
you feeling right there excited excited
that's nice
I'd like you to think of a specific peak
experience and once you experience a
peak of ecstasy I'm talking screaming
ecstasy
can you think of do you remember a
particular moment I'd like you to go
right before the peak of that moment how
much you remember right near the peak of
that experience
sincerely can you actually put yourself
there and remember it I should do that I
want you to step into that image this if
you were really there and breathe the
way you're breathing right near the peak
I get thrown in jail and as you're doing
that I want you to focus on what you
were focusing on right near the peak
and I breathe the way you're breathing
see what you're seeing here what you
were hearing were you making sounds at
this point were you seriously it made
that sound now come on give her a hand
ladies and gentlemen
don't put the microphone down give
yourself the gift my point is really
simple instead of getting the point
intellectually get at the point your
body cause intellectually oh yeah yeah I
know that's do it in your body actually
put yourself there and feel it sincerely
and make the sound it can be playful I
don't think there's anybody who hasn't
many sounds make some noises of your own
ladies and gentlemen help her out okay
see what you saw Bri the way you're
breathing near the peak move the way
you're moving in your body feel like
you're moving that way now make the
sounds at the peak that you're making
some of the sounds on the count of three
but really sincerely do it with your
voice the way it really would be one two
three go that's how loud you were huh
make the sounds go for it - yo you
weren't making any sounds I think it
said will you or you get really
spiritual like oh god oh god are you
more like more that was the do me more
kind of thing
now notice they have moving faster now
what are you feeling right now stay in
that thing what are you feeling right
now she's feeling so much she can't talk
now go back to the pressure better no go
back to the pressure come on you've been
there for years go to depression come on
you can't put your past behind you keep
your past right there in front of you so
you can stare at it maybe you don't want
to put your past behind you maybe this
past you want to put right in front of
you because you can't put your past
behind you in this case I think that's a
very good thing because if this was
constantly in front of you imagine the
smile that would be on your face all day
maybe you've been selective about which
past to put in front of you or behind
you the reason we get so down on
ourselves is because we're too busy in
our own inner worlds we get so wrapped
up and muddling of the day that we
forget about everyone else if you want
to change your situation start doing
stuff for others volunteer for others I
mean you will never run out of things to
do for other people you'll start to
realize that it's not about you life
wasn't never meant about you you'll
finally realize that it really isn't
that bad you'll start to realize that
there's hope after all and you'll
finally realize that you can transcend
whatever hard situation you're going
through didn't you suffer from
depression yes yes I'm on a manic high
right now
okay still how did how did you get
through that to this well that's another
thing you know at the risk of like
opening up the whole Tom Cruise Prozac
argument I you know I don't disagree in
many ways I think Prozac and things like
that are very valuable to people at for
short periods of time but I believe if
you're on them for an extended period of
time you never get to the problem you
never get to see what the problem is
because everything is just kind of okay
and so you don't deal and people deal
when they get desperate so how did you
do it I take supplements right oh yes
there is a well it's not well it is
vitamins but it's
so a certain elements of the brain like
tyrosine and hydroxy tryptophan that
they're treating depression with now and
and it is a natural substance that's in
your brain but instead of being a
serotonin inhibitor which doesn't you
know which just uses the serotonin you
have and Prozac and things like that it
just uses the serotonin you have and it
doesn't allow it to go back into the
receptor but it metabolizes your
serotonin after a while you have to keep
taking more and more so to feel good and
this actually creates dopamine and
creates serotonin and it's a wonderful
thing and it's amazing I'm going to talk
about a lot about it in the near future
but I read about it yeah as coming
through this made you a better performer
I think do you think I think all
experience if you're a performer if
you're if you're an artist you ought to
be able to take this table and make it
into something you know you ought to be
able to make something out of anything
exercise is good for us how many of you
can I see a show of hands how many of
you came in here today knowing that
exercises is really really good for us
right every hand goes up now is that
changed your behavior for some yes
everybody knows that exercise is good
for us here's the problem many people
have trouble making it happen and you
know what a lot of people don't realize
just how good exercise I'm going to say
something that may be a little bit
controversial or go ahead and say it and
I'm not speaking metaphorically exercise
is medicine
exercise literally is medicine it
changes the brain and the body in
beneficial ways that are more powerful
than any pill you can take yeah I said
it more powerful than any pill you can
in fact I'm going to say something even
more controversial if you could take the
neurological and physiological effects
of exercise and capture them in a pill
all the beneficial effects on neural
signaling in the brain the anti-aging
effects all the way down to the level of
chromosomes in every cell of your body
the mental clarity enhancing effects
I believe tell me if you think I'm crazy
I believe that pill would become the
best-selling drug of all time
and I think people would pay any price
to have it there's a problem though we
don't exercise we don't CDC again tells
us that 60% of all American adults get
no regular physical activity and yet if
we look at hunter-gatherer groups they
get four or more hours of vigorous
activity every day in fact they look
like elite athletes even when they're in
middle age and beyond here's the thing I
love though if you ask them they will
tell you they do not exercise they don't
they do not work out working out would
be crazy to them what do they do they
live they live here is yeah I know I
know I like it too
here's the dirty little secret in the
business and I really want you to if you
remember nothing else in this talk
exercise is not natural we are designed
to be physically active in the service
of adaptive goals we are not designed to
exercise when you put a lab rat on a
treadmill and crank that thing up to the
point where it's moving faster than it
wants to move you know what it'll do if
you let it
it'll squat down on its haunches and the
treadmill starts to wear the fur and the
skin right off its backside so it kind
of feels our pain right when you stare
at a piece of exercise equipment there
is a piece of your brain that's
screaming out don't do it you're not
going anywhere on that thing
so how do we solve this conundrum in our
treatment program we've done two things
we've made exercise natural and we've
made it social what's the most natural
activity in the world walking and guess
what brisk walking you know the kind
like you're late for the bus like you
might miss your plane
that kind of walking will get your pulse
up in the aerobic range and that's where
it needs to be based on your age
depending on your age that needs to be
but your pulse needs to be between about
120 and 150 that's enough to enhance
signaling and your dopamine circuits
your serotonin circuits it's been tested
head-to-head against Zoloft
twice in a long term it won at what dose
30 minutes three times a week that's a
low dose it can change your life all you
have to do is change the way you think
and it goes from being a miserable
experience or a tough experience or hard
experience to to one that you can do
anything that you want with and when I
my mother got her family all back
together again when I was nine nine
almost ten years old and I can remember
her telling me what it was like when I
was just a baby when I was just like an
infant that I was I was the one child
that could make everybody else laugh
that's at times when when everybody else
would she said we were waiting for a bus
one time when we were just real babies
before I went into the orphanage and she
said a car came by and there was it was
in Detroit and there was all this slush
and it just and we all went flying down
we got everybody had dirt on them and
dirty snow and we were laying in the car
in the ground and everybody was crying
and she said you were though and upset
and mad because their clothes were wet
and so on and she said you just stood up
and said this is great isn't this
wonderful look you know we don't have to
do this and we don't it was just turning
it into something positive it's like so
the ability to be able to do that was
something I can't remember a time in my
life when I didn't know that
if I if I really went to work on how I
thought that things just didn't have to
be bad
I was the richest kid in the orphanage I
was that's why I've talked about that
many times in my lectures that a
snowstorm was a time we we had one we
had two snow shovels at the FE at the at
the home and one of them
one of them had the the edges all curled
up from hitting the curbs and you
couldn't make any money with that one so
the other one when it would snow I would
go downstairs and I would take the good
snow shovel and I would put it under my
bed and I'd sleep with it right right
with me in the bed so that nobody else
would get it and I would get up before
everybody else got up and I would go out
and I would just shovel everybody else
to snow to shovel the walk and then
later on and I just go knock on the door
and just tell them that I shoveled their
walk and they'd say some would say thank
you and some would give me a dime which
doesn't sound like much but that's about
three thousand dollars in today's money
so and when I found out that soda pop
bottles for example were we're worth 2
cents each that if you took them back
you could get 2 cents back that was just
like one of the great awarenesses and
all kind of awakenings of my life
because I would follow people around who
were drinking a coca-cola say you almost
done with that well no I'm not glass
wall just whenever you win I just follow
them and watch until and I had a whole
we had a coal bin where we live because
it was coal furnaces and and I would we
fill that coal bin with with soda pop
bottles and I would take it but it was
just always it was just always easy to
change and all the other kids would be
and not having any money and complaining
about not being able to have abundance
or being able to have some some level of
being able to by themselves so it's just
a little donut or a Pepsi Cola or
something that they couldn't figure it
out and it always seems so easy to me
that all you had to do is just look
around and see the opportunities and
anything and it it had nothing to do
with whether there are opportunities
there
there always are opportunities I mean
I'm 67 years old I have never ever been
unemployed or even can't even deal with
the concept of unemployment it isn't
that I've had no job I've always had
more jobs than I've
and it isn't because I've been through
all good economic times they've been
there been some pretty sour economic
times over the last 50 years or so I
just have never known how to think any
other way then if you change the way you
think about things you can create
whatever it is you want for yourself in
your life thank you so much for watching
we made this video because intimidating
access to it so there's a topic that you
want me to cover in next edition of
believe life leave it below and I'll see
what I can do have a great day
continue to believe I'll see you soon